I saw Wall Street journal's article
recently came out with values I'm sure
you saw that as well yeah the collapse
of the American values patriotism that's
right involvement having children and
going to church have just descended in
meaning but money is up money is up yeah
and that's that hyper individualism
that's what you were talking about again
I am a capitalist I think that markets
work but they must be in harmony with
other duties that make the money meaning
meaningful otherwise it's just nothing
more than pleasure or things that will
erode and dust so it must Point towards
something you must aim high that was the
Western ideal right and that's why the
Declaration is such a beautiful document
it mentions God four times and in fact
in the end of The Declaration it's
basically a prayer we don't teach this
to our kids it's an appeal it says we
appeal to the Supreme judge of the world
and they're pointing High to something
larger than themselves it's very
platonic to use a phrase that was
earlier that there's things that we
can't quite feel that it cannot be
looked at in a you know cannot be looked
at in a microscope but we know they're
real we know love we know Justice we
know Mercy we know kindness we know
compassion is real and in fact we need
to build a society around that with the
post-modernist and the
post-structuralists have done post 1960s
is they basically say if it's not
Material if you can't see it and cause
an effect it's not real
and that's that's a that's a tragedy to
believe and so yes the the byproduct of
that is so you have two things happening
at once America pulls back from its
values that wants to find can you go to
the uh yeah it's very powerful but then
the they kind of buried the lead in fact
they didn't incorporate it which I just
want to reiterate it is a fact that we
are the most depressed most suicidal
most anxious most medicated most alcohol
addicted in history now you might say
well Charlie that's causation and
correlation hard to say that they aren't
connected hard to say that if patriotism
religion Community involvement having
kids collapses and all the negative
indicators Skyrocket that there isn't
some sort of relationship there what Tom
what do you think needs to happen for uh
uh a man to get on his knees and say I
need God what do you think needs to
happen for that to take place to a
nation great crisis builds great
response in the heart of any man after 9
11 you saw the unification of America in
an amazing way because whenever you have
a great crisis you you will inherently
point back to a great tenet or a great
truth and what happened on 9 11 the
great truth was Nobody messes with the
greatest country in the world and I'm
part of that and I'm proud to be part of
that and I'm coming together with my
neighbors and I'm upset about this and
I'm healing together and I'm mourning
together and I'm angry together together
the word together keeps coming and age
of moral relativism as we see here
everybody's truth is okay so starting in
1968 69 if you were to study that there
were about four things that came
together that make it very
understandable for a crack in the heart
of the populace in the population one is
you know you have the death of Bobby
Kennedy the death of Martin Luther King
You've Got The Summer of Love you've got
the senseless these people that believe
the senseless sending to war of um of
our young men if you if you didn't get
into college you're going to war tough
you know if you manage to get into
college oh so if your family could get
you into college you don't have to go to
war well you know talk to algor and W
about that they both took advantage of
that privilege to stay out of the war
and there was this crack that happened
there you had the loss of these leaders
you had the also the loss of faith in
the in the in the Elders of the time
because what was happening there and the
great Summer of Love where everybody
thought well then all your truths will
be okay that was well intended but what
happened in the middle of that is if
everybody's truth is okay pbd then
there's no one ruler for standard for
morals there's no one ruler for
standards of what is patriotism what is
faith in America or what is good or what
do we do for our community and suddenly
everybody's truth is okay and you can't
judge me becomes the the boomerang that
comes back the unintended consequences
is you lose control of the whole thing
and so I think great crisis is needed
what will bring America back together
and unfortunately great crises are
usually very painful in their own right
can I say of course that was really
beautifully put I'm you I didn't even
think about the college enrollment draft
thing prior the issue though Patrick is
that if you have moral chaos tyranny
comes next and there's a totalitarian
impulse that is running through our
country we call it identity politics
political correctness is that the the
the the answer to this will not be more
freedom or more Liberty in the short
term it's that it's going we're going to
need instruments of meaning so then
we're going to need somebody to tell you
what to do which is one of the reasons
why I think this covidian fascism was
accepted by so many Americans for so
long and so you get strong leaders quote
unquote strong leaders if the moral
fiber of your country decays if I can
just add to that I
I believe everything you're saying is
accurate I also think that there's sort
of a messaging problem because
you talked about the Joel Osteen's of
the world or even the Mark Wahlberg's of
the world
who do you think is more likely to
convert the everyday person to love
America and to fear God again Joel
Osteen or a Mark Wahlberg type I would
argue that you need this in the pop
culture Zeitgeist it's not going to take
a religious leader or some sort of
apostle that's going to convert everyday
Americans and start loving Americans
again or go to church more often it's
not going to be religious leader you see
the fastest growing religion in America
these days is atheism and agnosticism
right non-denominational or just
non-believer yes
um so we need to kind of like what
you're saying we need to make loving
America again and American values and
judeo-christian values pop culture and
cool again and until that's done I think
we're going to have the same
conversation for years and years without
my argument is that the American
founding is the great rallying point I
think that it's so beautiful it's so
exceptional
it's so rare in human history and it
also I think people yearn to actually
love the place they live in I know
that's an unusual thing to say I think
people actually want an excuse to love
America and so I think the promise of
the founding can be that great unifying
that you could disagree on tax policy
disagreeing immigration but let's at
least agree that these Founders were
onto something very big bold and
beautiful and we're recipients from and
then understand what that is we got a
real conversation about that if I can
give you one thing for that if that's
the answer which it might okay which it
is so you remember the movie The Patriot
yeah Mel Gibson by the way is a
Christian that would be I mean talk
about what happened to him after passion
to the Christ yeah well he's doing
number two now yeah but that movie I
don't know if that uh preceded Passion
of the Christ and Braveheart are you
kidding me yeah but that guy made loving
America and fighting for America cool
and in the pop culture so it's going to
take something like that kind of what I
was saying in the pop culture to make
Young Americans 16 is not proud to be
American you're not going to get him to
start loving America by saying hey read
the Declaration of Independence buddy I
acknowledge that yeah I'm not even trust
me try to get them to read the the
preamble to the Constitutions let alone
the first paragraph of one of the course
human events that comes necessary when
people dissolve the political bands that
have time to another to get them to even
read that like what does that even mean
I'm talking about the Eternal compelling
truth behind it right that maybe and if
not then we're a lot farther gone than I
would like to believe but I totally
agree I mean Tom Cruise's top gun
Maverick praise God that that was the
number one movie in the last year and a
half yeah I think that is evidence in my
favor that people enjoyed kind of the
pro Americana Vibe right the kind of you
know we're gonna go up against the bad
guys there was no bad guy who named the
bad guy no that's what it was
interesting there was no country they
didn't identify it almost it was just
about America intentionally abstract
almost right and it was about rallying
behind a team and it really didn't
Pander that much to Identity politics I
mean it was a little bit throughout but
it was largely a movie that could have
been made in the 80s or 90s which is why
it was so successful you know you know
you know what I think needs to happen
this is my ideas okay on this first of
all for me uh uh the enemy if you study
enemy how it did whatever it did it
always divided if I if a if a person
today we're having a meeting upstairs
we're having a managers meeting and I
said the biggest challenge in a in a
marriage who's the biggest enemy in a
marriage the biggest enemy is when the
spouse becomes the marriage it's always
better to have an external enemy than an
internal enemy the worst type of enemy
is the internal enemy we have internal
enemies right now and the way they're
doing it is they they're going they're
so brilliant dark but brilliant they're
going straight to the top of influence
and they're crippling them
straight to the top but did you see what
he did but did you see what she did but
your parents they don't know what
they're doing your parents don't care
about you if your parents came out they
would probably judge you you know what
this is how we are we are a little bit
more desperate so they're dividing to
the point of influence okay whatever the
influence is now Mel Gibson may be a guy
who I can watch all day his movies I
think is fantastic I think it's funny he
can do funny I think he can do you know
drama he can do anything put him
anywhere he's going to do great right
but I think you need to get somebody
like the face of the NBA the face of the
NFL the face of Hollywood like it needs
to be a rock type it needs to be a
Michael type a LeBron type A Brady type
a person like that that's willing to
talk so if they're gonna work that way
to come and take the influence from the
top you got to go get some of the guys
at the top so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]